we're gonna call you Michael
alright Michael Michael where'd you grow
up where you from
nothing just got a flame which part of
it that way south-central okay no tell
me about your family get both your
parents growing up yeah my mom pass 1205
my dad passed I was like 20-something my
grandma raised me up like my life she's
got cancer
I'm sorry so you raised by your
grandmother and you're dead yeah my
grandma wasn't grandma where's dad he
was a professional boxer so he was there
he was Tims there but you know I mean he
got older and passed off how was your
childhood it was like it was kind of
rough this kind of rebel war know what
kind of stuff babe use nice just man
just growing up rough light and John
gale type of stuff what's the kind of
the worst thing you had to go through
here as a kid I run away from home
getting whooped and said getting hit
with switches and extension cords and
stuff like that my mom said I know look
out older my grandmother says the whole
house was like just all drug addicts and
stuff like that
what was your way when you left home
no what age were you when you left home
I was running away at eleven oh really
yeah and what are you doing on the
streets at 11:00 for Mike said picking
up cans and stuff for selling a bike of
something something like that yeah and
today you're you're supporting yourself
huh yeah
seven doh drugs are you selling mostly
cristela we never and you're selling
here on Skid Row
yeah yeah I've said around here just
five have you done any prison talk to
that
yeah I don't do gonna do prison time to
what I have 16 once
I never prison time behind it told you
I'm 38
yeah you have kids of your own yeah
daughter I would Gardens for iron did
you raise her no not really cuz I was
out here in the streets on drugs and he
lived in Street stuff so you're you're
used to I used to not anymore I used to
know your you're clean now
yeah and who you're selling to most of
the people would you see here it's good
rugged yeah they're on gay people people
that's around here yeah
Yeah right yours hmm your regulars right
yeah right yeah
thank you yeah daily how much how much
do people spend a day typically live in
panic probably comforted $150 they
probably come through eighty dollars
forty dollars whenever they come without
goes from for a day they're spending
that yeah they come without give them
some for it right
you have to worry about the police and
getting yeah you always have to worry
about the police you have taking chances
though I'm gonna and children you know I
mean so yeah take yet don't worry about
it
what's your view I mean you're providing
a service for something that these
people want do you see a role in their
addiction do you see yourself is like
part of that destruction that they're
you're putting on themselves yeah I see
a partner I see a part of the
destruction that they put it on itself
because I was a part of it too and I see
myself being destructed too but I called
myself and I snapped out of it yeah how
do you I mean when you when you see them
and they're just getting worse and worse
do you ever like give them advice or
tell them anything or yeah talk to
always talk to him cause he's doing yes
talk to somebody that means there's
somebody he's always something on
somebody lies somebody might need to let
off so I'll speak to everybody talked
every but I treat everybody just saying
well I want to be treated better than
today they still need what they need it
didn't end a nice to know what they need
and you're you have a son or daughter
I have a daughter the daughter yeah and
you still have contact with her not
really cuz I really don't know where
they went to and everything everybody
just disappeared so I haven't seen her
in a minute yeah you're looking back at
your childhood do you think your mom was
out of the picture very early your dad
was kind of out of the picture a lot of
sounds like a lot of physical abuse yeah
do you think that kind of led you into
this lifestyle and yeah played a big
part in it so here your play here you
are 38 in your I'll here any streets out
here in the streets yeah pretty big part
in it yeah what do you wish I mean when
you were a young boy did you have dreams
of a different life when I was now I
always wanted to be a fireman I just
thought that was cool there'd be a
fireman and well I've got older just
ended up with the wrong crowd and ended
up gang begging son of drugs and when I
ran in the street we're getting some
party you're like yeah it was pretty
part of my life yeah gangs and drugs
kind of go together
yes all in one package yeah
you think you grew up in another part of
the country I'm a totally different
person I'd be a totally different person
a very different person
you have friends ears you've seen
you know not long prison sentences and
death yeah for I have friends around my
friends around have friends the past you
know I have friends that not friends
anymore you know I hear this street life
is always going to be like that what do
you think the solution of the problem is
for me I think find me a job or
something or find me a lady that that
understand me and understand the streets
like I think a lady they understand how
the streets really work from her being
out here in these streets from doing bad
to doing good
I need a lady like that so therefore
she'd know how to deal with me and she
know how to work with me and
understanding before no have you been
before yeah yeah when it don't go good
it hurts okay okay I give you in high
school I've never even made I went to
all the special ed schools all
continuations all my schools have
probation officers in handcuffs the
first time you started using was at what
age about 12 start off smoking pretty
laws which is okay creo cocaine we how
do you think all these years of doing
this living this lifestyle exchanging
it changed me lockers I'm a grown man
bro man and survive while here I gotta
survive so you know I just try to live
one day at a time yeah did you have role
models when you were kid no nothing no
just the streets yeah my role models
telling how to sell drug steal cars and
write a walls all right Michael well
thank you so much for sharing your story
no problem good luck wherever you go
from here
yeah no problem thank you
you